I'm mostly excited I think these days
about kinds of technologies calls mixed
reality technologies or sometimes
they're called hybrid technologies
mobile phones are part of this we have a
motion capture lab at the school that
allows kids to work with wireless
controllers like on the Wii so games
that bleed between sort of physical
activity physical real-world spaces and
digital spaces I'm really interested in
this notion of getting the game off the
screen and thinking about gameplay as a
kind of lamination over top real-world
kinds of physical spaces and I think
technology is getting to a place where
that blended pneus is something that's
really possible today it used to be a
very science fictiony idea a couple
years ago people talked about alternate
reality all the time and you were
wearing these giant headsets be our
headsets and it just felt impossible
that that could be fun but technology
has evolved to a point where you can now
really think about gameplay being
blended with physical kind of real-world
spaces and that to me is is really
exciting there's also been a lot of work
around artificial intelligence and sort
of digital characters recognizing
conversations with people and so I again
it gets into that blended notion of how
do we allow digital characters to feel
slightly more real than they do it in a
sort of purely fictional space and and
to me that's that's a really interesting
an interesting area to look at I tend to
be more interested in this notion of
playing games as part of the real world
and that's why the physical space ideas
are really of interest to me and why
mobile phones I think are increasingly
of interest as game platforms the iphone
has changed everything i think in terms
of thinking about digital games and
gameplay and where games sit who plays
them what those games might be like and
that's really exciting I think
the thing that interest to me about
interest me really about games is the
social fabric component of it the fact
that I am in this game with other people
and my interactions with them can become
increasingly interesting over time
depending on whether they're a friend or
foe in this space and so I'm very
interested in games that catalyze many
many people to be playing together but
maybe doing that in an alternate reality
game sort of fit into the genre where
I'm doing things in my in the real world
that also may begin to have effects in a
kind of digital virtual world so I'm
very interested in how beyond the social
how data can flow between actions and
the real world and actions in a game
there's this whole new genre of games
that have just popped up called extra
games that connect exercise to gaming
and there's these ideas where you're
tracking how many steps people take and
its power that's powering up your
Pokemon there's a little device called
the Polka Walker that you can attach to
your shoe or carry with you and it's
like constantly powering up your video
game characters and I'm really
interested in that the data flow between
something and activity I might be doing
in the real world and some implication
in a virtual environment and also
potentially vice versa and so that's
more about notions of consequence and
impact and how that might change social
relations between who's in that game and
what they're doing together
well generally I I put someone in a game
I play with them I think one of the
reasons that there's been a lot of
criticism around games is there's a lot
of over-the-shoulder journalism going on
when it comes to games so it's people
that are standing over the shoulder of a
player watching something that's
happening on the screen and when you
just look at a game you get a very
different sense of what it's really
about than if you're playing it and so
the first thing I always do is I take
people out of that over the shoulder
position and I actually put the
controller in their hands so we might
play together play something together at
the school we have visitors all the time
that come in that say well can you
explain the school to me can you explain
the school to me and i always take them
to this motion capture lab that we have
that we've designed games with teachers
for the kids in and i actually give them
a controller and we play a game together
and once they've had that experience
they understand the model of the school
and they understand what we're trying to
get at in terms of how the structure of
the game can really lead to engaging and
deep learning for kids so that's so
that's one thing you can't just read
about it games are experiential things
and it's really important to play